sara bareilles joins us right now good
morning i like that color on it thank
you
good in the morning yeah so so what does
it mean to be part of this beloved
show's second revival on broadway it is
so special i mean and this isn't my
first time doing
a stephen sondheim show and it's the
first production that's been mounted
since his passing as well you know that
the company is on broadway right now but
this is the first
uh show that's gone through a process of
being put up without steve in the room
so it's it's poignant in a lot of ways
and and the themes of the show
are so resonant right now it's battling
giants it's you know what is coming at
you our humanity getting sort of
pushed to the brink and where we break
and where we fail and you say it's
always timely how so this the show so
james lapine who's the book writer the
script writer shared this story with us
when we were in our our meet and greet
for for the city center production of
the show
um he said it was written in and around
the aids crisis so that was the first
time it came to be and the second time
it was revived was after 9 11. and here
we are in sort of the third time on
broadway and yeah it's really along with
other things yeah i mean i'm dealing
with this along with other things i love
the exchange in the green room but john
lepuku has seen it was raving about you
so as shauna thomas the big cheese
around here everyone's saying you were
so great so john says to sarah so do you
have perfect pitch and she says no but
i'm a very good singer
i love that little subtle flavor
oh no i love it i can't you can't say
sing me a c or you know sing it be flat
no i can't find it
my favorite row when you're in the
theater because it's right in the middle
oh so i was there opening night you
wrote you sang the lyrics to that how
about that i mean that's that's trifecta
yeah thank you talk about a flex yeah so
how is this different preparing for into
the woods compared to waitress i loved
you and waitress well
i i mean thank you so much waitress is
the great love of my artistic life but i
it was really amazing to come in just as
an interpreter you know to not have my
relationship to the material of waitress
was you know years and years of
workshops and working on other people
and and so this was a really interesting
kind of experiment as an actor and and
to come in and find who is my baker's
wife and there it's it's
you know it's been there's incredible
performances of this very iconic role
over the years and and
but that's what i love about theater you
can you can feel like you know a show
but on different casts it has a
different flavor and
i think our cast is exceptionally
special so as a lyricist and a composer
when you approach material like stephen
sondheim's material what is that like
yeah what is that like just post panic
attack
right on there i mean let me tell you
this is hard this this is a
dense show oh my gosh hard how wow it is
so it's it's complicated the themes are
complicated the lyrics are complicated
it's really dense there's it's very
wordy
and then the first time we did at city
center we had 10 days to learn the show
and i didn't know the show going into it
so like you want me to memorize excuse
me what
into the woods to get the what to die
right
there are plenty of finales where i just
would turn up stage and just like mouth
something you talk about healing energy
um what do you mean by that and how has
it personally
healed you
for me i mean i
this is why i love doing theater i mean
what we are seeing happen in the
audiences is so
extraordinary and i think people are
realizing they're getting something
they didn't even know they were hungry
for i needed they really needed this
there's something about the fact that
this this story is woven through fairy
tale that i think kind of awakens
something childlike and i think it's a
really cynical time and so people it's
true i see some people talk about the
show as being sort of like oh it's an
escape but i actually think it's just
dealing it's dealing with this very
intense subject matter but in a way
where you can actually
it's digested yeah
yeah you can engage because
you know we softened the blow a little
bit well you know what i mean i wanted
to go season three of girls five ever
amen
amen
out the world favorite sarah bareilles
song mine is brave because i think it's
helped so many people at different times
do you have a favorite sara bareilles
song that that is one of them
has really taught me a lot and anytime
you can see something you make
sort of
become to belong to
everybody else that feels really special
a lot of people a lot of ways so you're
there until august so august 22nd yeah
august 21st and we need to get there
before come see the show yes yes yes
done and done we thank you thank you